es ist schon verrückt der kuiper gürtel
ist ganz anders als erwartet
denn eigentlich wurden dort unzählige
kleine objekte erwartet aber sie sind
gar nicht da was ist da draußen los
klick zum science fiction
hier gibt es täglich spannende science
videos abonniert den kanal nur dann
verpasst ja nichts los geht's dann haben
sie bekommen wenn sonden in den weltraum
fliegen dann bringen sie meist wirklich
sehr überraschende bahnbrechende
erkenntnisse beim saturnmond enceladus
stieß die raumsonde cassini auf hinweise
auf außerirdisches leben oder eben jetzt
new horizons die sonde die das weites
entfernte von menschen bisher aus der
nähe untersuchte objekt genauer unter
die lupe nahmen ultima thule war nicht
nur extrem seltsam geformt sondern hatte
auch eine eigenschaft die die
forschungsteams stutzig macht er wenige
krater zu wenige krater
denn eigentlich hätte der himmelskörper
übersät sein müssen mit krater denn der
aktuelle stand der wissenschaft vermutet
im kupfergürtel also dem
asteroidengürtel rund um unser
sonnensystem jenseits des neptun
unzählige kleinere objekte und die
müssen auf objekten wie ultima thule
einschlagen und spuren hinterlassen aber
die gibt es nicht und auch auf dem pluto
mond sharon fehlen diese spuren
eigentlich müssten objekte mit einem
durchmesser von 90 metern bis zu 1,6
kilometern auf beiden objekten spuren
hinterlassen haben aber pustekuchen
nichts der kuipergürtel ist einfach ganz
anders als gedacht und auch anders als
der asteroidengürtel zwischen mars und
jupiter
denn der ist voller solcher objekte die
die erde dazu noch ständig bedrohen wir
berichten immer wieder über drohende
anschläge und solche die auch immer
wieder stattfinden
das forschungsteam um kelsey singer vom
southwest research institute ist ab denn
nach ihren ergebnissen muss der körper
gürtel ganz anders entstanden sein als
der asteroidengürtel zwischen mars und
jupiter wo immer wieder objekte
zusammengestoßen und neue arten
entstehen im kupfergürtel scheint das
anders zu verlaufen
dort existieren wohl viel weniger dieser
objekte und das wirft auch wieder ein
neues licht auf die these dass es gar
kein planet 9 geben würde sondern eher
aus einem ring aus zehntausenden
objekten mit
genommen seiner vermuteten masse quasi
simuliert werde wenn diese ergebnisse
aber stimmen dann ist es keinesfalls
klar dass solche asteroiden ringe immer
voll gestopft mit solchen objekten sind
und auch bei planet 9 wird die existenz
eines solchen rings stark bezweifelt die
jetzige entdeckung dürfte diese
vermutung nochmal bestärken und die
existenz von planeten wahrscheinlicher
machen so weit draußen gebe es demnach
gar nicht solche riesigen material
wolken oder zumindest sind sie anders
zusammengesetzt als bisher vermutet das
könnte dann auch für die orte wolke noch
weiter draußen gelten aber all das sind
bloße vermutung aber sie zeigen auf
jeden fall wie wenig wir noch selbst
über unser eigenes sternsystem wissen
das sonnensystem spannendes video
unbedingt draufklicken anschauen und
raumzeit lockt der zukunft abonnieren
bis dann bleibt dran